sir it is an honor to be sitting across
from you to talk to you about anything
my own I I even did a
um how do you feel when someone is
wearing a bootleg t-shirt of one of your
movies oh I
feel happy I it was so nice I feel like
I have a friend you know I have a very
good friend you know as a friend give me
to always give me the great support you
know sir um you have done in my opinion
some of just such iconic action scenes
through your career if if someone has
never seen a John Woo movie what is the
one you'd like them starting with and
why well I would like them to starting
with you know one of my Hong Kong movie
called A Better Tomorrow a tomorrow
there was the first uh my uh uh aour
movie you know it was the first time
yeah I really could do whatever I want
you know all all the you know shooting
with two guns and all the action all
slow motion all start from that movie
and then after tomorrow the killer hot
boy you know and bully in the head you
know those movie and also uh they can
watch face off you know you know also my
favorite
movies uh anyway so and but and at this
time sat night of course I have a ton of
questions but I have one more um as a
fan of your work and a lot of people
want to see your earlier films in 4k uh
Ultra HD do you know if there's any
plans for like the killer or hardboiled
or a better tomorrow uh to be in 4k no
um uh I don't think so because I uh I
don't ow the right you know and I uh for
the uh production company they have so
everything to a uh uh to another company
you so I uh I I tried to do it but I but
I couldn't you know because because I
don't hold sure well what I I pray it
happens at some point jumping into why I
get to talk to you you've done so many
things in your career but I don't
believe you've ever made a movie without
dialogue so what was it like for you to
to helm something like this you know uh
first of all I really love the script
you know it really excites me you know I
always like to take a challenge you know
I'm a fighter you know I like to always
try to do something new something
unexpected you know like when I read a
script I feel uh by the meantime you
know uh uh uh it also had a very
heartful you know meaningful story you
know uh especially the the whole story
about the young little kid you know the
innocent kid being murdered you know by
the gangster I I I I think is pretty you
know close to the real life you know in
real life you know it could happen to
any any family of anybody so I uh uh so
I feel strongly with the story and and
by the meantime is uh since that they
have no dial uh it will allow me to
using the the visual and the sound uh
you know more to tell him the story and
then make the audience to
uh understand beside understanding the
whole story and what you can feel with
the character you know so and then the
uh which
is is a good TR for me one of the things
is um you craft such great action
sequences and I'm curious how much are
you figuring things out on set and how
much are you doing it in advance before
you're stepping on set and how much
changes while you're there well in this
movie I get uh try to you know create a
new kind of style for myself you know
and I did
use uh the uh what I usually to do the
like you know my uh usually my kind of
movie is have kind of like a the action
look pretty fancy and look pretty you
know and graphic and and uh sometimes a
little uh romantic but I in this movie I
trying to make it more more realistic
and all the fight all the fight I need
look like a real fight and and actually
it's a really real fight and then before
we we are
preparing the the movie and just and I
work with my son team you know I just
told him you know and I all I need real
fight forget about you know other action
movie know forget about the Sci-Fi thing
they no sci-fi there I want real I want
a real thing so uh so uh they have took
about two months you know fishing uh all
the action scenes you know every just
practic with an actor with with Joe you
know and then I just watch t what they
what they have shown me and then so
while we shooting I would like to uh
using uh one long take one long take to
shoot the their fight and then make it
look more of a real and more honest
and every punch every every you know hit
they all real so that they will uh
instead of you know like some of
action movie they to use a second camera
or you know shop record but I I didn't
use it I just want to show the uh let
the audience feel more more involved you
know on that note sir it is an absolute
honor to meet you have a fantastic
afternoon thank you so
much